und vor allen Dingen bei denen der
ganzen Kritik und die ganzen Skandalen
die hier schon beim rbb gewesen sind ist
das glaube ich das falsche Signal und
vor allen Dingen wenn ich immer wieder
denke wir sollen den Gürtel irgendein
enger schneiden und dann gibt's so eine
Abfindung ich meine ja wie heißt immer
so die oberen 10.000 davon haben wir 700
und ein paar 30 im Bundestag die genauso
abgehoben sind ich denke man sollte
vielleicht mal überlegen ob diese
Gebühren nicht anders einzusetzen sind
vor allen Dingen für auch Probleme die
wir in unserem Land haben oder ja dann
müssen ja andere auch private Sender
müssen ja auch sich selbst ihr Geld
herbeizaubern vielleicht sollten die das
auch mal aber wir werden sehen was die
Zukunft bringt denn das ist definitiv
das heißt das Signal und ich als Bürger
kann schon sagen auch über das was ich
teilweise da sehe was der öffentliche
Rundfunk zeigt besonders in den letzten
zweieinhalb Jahren der Pandemie würde
ich sagen ich würde eigentlich schon
bald sagen wir zahlen mal nicht mal
gucken was passiert wegsperren können
Sie uns alle nicht